Hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new video. Today we're going to be doing
something that has been suggested quite
a few times and that is overnight
flipping or bot dump flipping. Um it's
really easy to do and can actually be
pretty profitable on items that normally
are not. So we have a um kind of a small
list of items open here. Uh air orbs,
black chinchas, dragon bones, green
dragon leather, magic logs, oak planks,
and red chinchas.
These aren't the only items you can do,
but uh just the ones that kind of popped
in my head. Um so you're going to need a
grand exchange tracking tool. I'm going
to use G Tracker because it actually
shows you the last half an hour and the
most up-to-date information. So we'll
jump into let's see the red chin
chompas.
So what we're going to look for is for
one having the buying quantities. Nice
7,000. And two, we want to go to the
most recent data. So down to the day or
the week if that's what you're using.
And um so we're going to look through
all the prices over the last uh this is
the last 24 hours. So an item naturally
has every day a kind of natural curve
going up and down up and down during
certain hours. Uh we're looking for when
it's at its lowest and then we'll just
put an offer in for that. It's really
simple. And then we'll just wait 24
hours and hopefully at that time uh the
supply and demand will be lower and you
will buy the items. And then you want to
hopefully sell it during a peak hour
when there's tons being traded and the
price is a bit higher.
Uh so for this example for wrench and
chompas uh low is about625
or something. Um, yeah. And you can sell
it hopefully for
H6.87.
You could put in for 1680. These numbers
aren't like 100% correct. They could be
could item could have gone higher or
lower. Um, but it's a good kind of
guide. So, if we did uh let's see 16
87US 1625 was it?
Yeah. And then times 7,000 is the limit.
Uh, we'd make about 434K.
and our investment would only be like
about 12 mil. Uh so pretty pretty good
return especially since this item will
not oftent times have a very big margin
if you just try to flip it normally. And
yeah, so that's kind of the basics of
it. And now we're going to try it out a
couple times with a bunch of different
items and we'll see it actually works.
Okay, so to start off we are going to
try the green dragon hide.
So, we have a G track Tracker open here,
and we're going to have a look at the
prices. So, there's a limit of 13,000
for the item. So, decently high. We're
going to go down to the day, and we're
going to look at the different prices
here. 1823.
Um, 1828 seems to be kind of one of the
higher points. Um, now it would be nice
if this was a feature, so I might
suggest it to the the guy who owns it,
actually being able to see right away
what the highest and lowest it's been
at. But it looks like it's between 1805
roughly and 1830 or 1828. So we could
probably get a 25 GP margin on it, which
is um not too bad. So we'll just give it
a try just to see how this works. Uh so
we'll put an offer in for 1806 and we'll
do let's see we'll do 13k. And uh to go
with the green dragon hive, we might go
with the dragon bones which is probably
one of the highest botted items of all
time. um loads traded every day. Um but
let's have a look at the day graph and
yeah, it's actually changed a good
amount even in the last 24 hours. Uh so
it was up to let's see 3256
uh 3299.
That's quite high. And right now it's
down the lowest point. Let's see 3100
something. 3299 3272. It's a little
annoying to find. 3213 is pretty low.
3170.
So, we can actually get a pretty large
margin on this item right now. Uh
assuming that um this is a natural trend
and not just a downward trend. Um
because if this is items just going
down, obviously that's not going to work
as well. Um but I think we'll definitely
try this cuz it does have a pretty high
point in the last 24 hours. Uh, so
dragon bones. And what should we put it
in for?
Going to try 3171.
And um let's see how many we can afford.
Can we afford 10,000? Uh, no. We'll have
to do 7,000.
And yeah, so we're just going to leave
this in probably for 24 hours, not
necessarily overnight, and we'll come
back and see how it works. Okay, so
unfortunately the green dragon hides uh
we didn't make any money on. We
accidentally bought them um instantly
when we changed the price. Uh we sold
them back for the same price, so it's
not a big deal. Uh but the dragon bones
we did all buy. It's been about uh left
in overnight and they were pretty much
all bought when I woke up. Uh so we
bought all the dragon bones for 3171 and
we're going to try selling them for
3,300. Now it's pretty high, so we're
not sure if we're going to sell them for
that much, but we might as well shoot
for the moon. That's like a 1 mil profit
right there. So hopefully we can sell
off the dragon bones and we'll come back
uh when some items have sold. Okay, so
we did uh sell off all the dragon bones
and uh for about a 300 or 350k profit.
So pretty decent uh for dragon bones
anyway. Um and we did put another offer
for the green dragon hides cuz we wanted
to give them a try since the first time
we ended up putting in a way too high a
number and messing up a little bit. Uh
but we didn't get a full 13k green
dragon hides. We only got about 6.5k of
them. And we bought them for how long
did we buy them for? I think 1806 or
something like that. And or maybe even a
little lower than that. I think it was
1791 actually.
So let's see what it Yeah. So now it's
at about 1835. That's a 40 or 50 GP
profit. Let's have a look at our history
quickly here. Yeah. 1791. Uh, so we're
going to pop these in here for$1835
and we'll see if we actually manage to
sell those off because if we do that
would be let's see 1835us 1791
a 44 GP margin time 6,000 is another 250
300k. Uh, so not bad and we'll see if we
can get a higher margin on some other
items though. So next up we're thinking
of trying the red chin Champa. Um, it
has a fair amount traded every Okay, so
let's look at the last day or two. Uh
low point 1579
seems to be one of the lower end of it.
Maybe put in for 1580 or something. Um
kind of looks maybe I'm crazy, but looks
like it's kind of trending up a little
bit. It's kind of hard to tell though.
Um but we'll put an offer in for roughly
1590 or actually 1580 maybe. And uh
we'll see how this works. Maybe dragon
items are just a bit too traded that the
bots dumping them don't even affect the
price too much. So, we'll put an offer
in for 10,000.
And yeah, we didn't instantly buy them,
which is probably good. Uh, next up, we
kind of were thinking of trying the U
logs. Now, it is a heavily boughted
item. It's not very expensive. In my
experience of doing this, it's better to
pick an item that is in 1,000 to kind of
5,000 range. So, if the item's too
cheap, the margin won't vary more than
it would regularly. Um, it might drop a
couple GP and who knows, maybe it would
work, but it just seems better to me to
pick a more expensive item. Doesn't have
to be like wildly expensive, but
something in like between 1,000 coins
and 10,000 coins per item would probably
be the most optimal. Um, but we're going
to try Ulogs anyway. um 13 or 359 seems
to be one of the lower points and we
could sell them for maybe 370
um which is like 11 GP uh which is
pretty decent for the money invested
since it only be like uh 3 or 4 mil to
get the full buying limit. Um so we'll
put an offer in for 360
um and uh do at least 10,000 and move on
to one more item.
And uh next up, we might try a plank. Uh
either regular planks or oak planks. Has
this really crazy curve on it. So it
might not be uh the most profitable item
or the most safe item. It probably would
be profitable because it is naturally
raising up quite a bit like in the last
day. Um it's rose like 30 GP. Uh last
week it's risen up quite a bit. Um so
it's a bit more of a volatile item, but
we might try it because it looks like it
might be trending up anyway. So who
knows? Could just be a good investment
anyway. Um 270 seems to be one of the
higher points. If we go back to exactly
24 hours ago, looks quite a bit lower,
closer to 225.
Um
so yeah, let's put an offering for
planks. Uh see how that goes. Um regular
planks we're going to do and we'll put
in for we're going to go a bit higher on
this one cuz it looks like the item is
raising up already. Uh do 257 and do
10,000 planks. And actually we have 10
left. We're probably going to do another
item. Maybe we'll do another plank. Um
maybe oak planks. We'll try. Okay, so
looking at oak planks. Um kind of looks
like it's trending. Actually, no. It
kind of looks pretty even. I might just
be crazy. Um but the low point looks
about 440.
And uh yeah, same kind of thing. It
looks like it's evening out over the
last week or two. Same kind of curve as
the regular planks a bit. Um but we'll
put it in for a low price of 440 maybe.
And uh do 10,000 of those and then I
think we're going to call it. But we'll
come back and see how many of these
items actually manage to work. Okay, so
these are the items that kind of ended
up sticking around. Um, the planks and
green dragon hides did actually sell.
Uh, the green dragon hides we got about
uh 300k in profit. Uh, the planks we
got, let's see here,
uh, about 270,
I think. Yeah. So, pretty decent for
what types of items they are. And we did
end up buying about 8,000 red
chinchampas. Um, so we'll have to go see
what we can sell them for. Um, let's go
to the day graph here and uh pop them in
for like 1615 or something. The actively
trade price is about that right now. And
we bought them for 1581. So we should
hopefully get a 30 GP margin in there at
least. Uh, actually hopefully we can get
up to 1638 or 1643
1660 even. Yeah, it's been quite a bit
higher in the last um 24 hours. So, I I
think we should be at least be able to
sell it for630.
Uh, so I think that's what we're going
to pop it in there for.638.
Sure. And I think we're going to try the
dragon bones one more time cuz this is
one of the items I've seen done
successfully quite a few times. Uh, so
we'd like to get a little bit of a
larger margin on at least once. We'll
give it a try though. Um, 3163
doesn't seem to have a huge variance in
the price though. Um,
but I don't know. It looks like we could
still get a 40 GP margin on it. Probably
buy around for what the price is now
seems to be the low points, 3160, and
hopefully sell it for 3,200. Okay, so I
just checked the margin and it's
actually at 3156, which is one of the
lowest in the last 24 hours. So, we're
just going to put an offer in for that
and uh we'll come back and see if the
dragon bones work better this time.
Okay, so we sold off both the red gin
chompas and the dragon bones. Uh the
dragon bones we got a 39 GP margin each
one and 9k dragon bones gives us a 351k.
Uh the red chin chompas we got actually
a 57 GP margin and we got a little bit
less. We got 8k of those but that gives
us 450k in profit. Uh so pretty decent u
for especially for items like I didn't
specifically pick out special items that
nobody knows about. These are consistent
items that people use all the time. We
just managed to get a higher margin of
them by just looking at the trends in
the last 24 hours. So, hope you guys
enjoyed the video. If you did, please
hit that subscribe button for more
guides like this, and I will see you
guys next time.
[Music]